okay so the penultimate episode of rings
of power season 1 has just released and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking it down putting out all a Lord
of the Rings Easter eggs and giving our
review on the episode as a whole episode
7 ends with the Awakening of a balrog as
well as a 1990s text reveal that
confirms the Southlands and our mortal
the balrog has the exact same look as it
does in the Peter Jackson movies and
though there were many designs of them
in the source material they've clearly
leaned into that now it is said in the
original trilogy that the dwarves in it
the balrog because they dug too deeply
and hastily into the mines when trying
to get more mithril however balrogs are
beasts that have been around for a long
time and they ended up joining melkor in
the unrecorded times they originally
lived in antono but they ended up being
after the war for the sake of the elves
and from here they traveled to angband
where they hibernated until The Heirs of
the trees after angolian destroyed them
the spider turned on morgoth and he
screamed to the point that it worked the
balrogs up they go through this constant
stage of either being awake or
hibernating or I bet there's no mention
of them during the second age which is
where the show predominantly takes place
the show changes the timeline a lot
whereas the balrog awakens here it
wasn't until a third age where the one
in kazadin Rosa we've talked about this
on other breakdowns and how it wasn't
until June the fourth was King that the
first one attacked this balrog ended up
killing him however I think for the show
that it will kill his father and then he
will take up the mantle this will still
allow it to have the nickname during
Spain even though the character and
events have been swapped around so
that's a basic breakdown of the balrog
and for the rest of the video we're
going to be going through the episode
scene by scene if you enjoy them please
hit the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe for breakdown take
this every day by the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into rings
of power foreign
the episode itself is called the eye
this has several meanings in Middle
Earth but predominantly it's referring
to sauron's eye which beaches heavily in
the main Trilogy I bet the eye of Sauron
was a symbol of the character long
before he became one and it stood for
his piercing gaze and how he looked over
everything and I was also spotted on the
weird group that are stalking the
stranger who we'll talk more about later
on in the video now the main exhaust
port in a volcano is also referred to as
an eye and we open the episode with a
focus on gladriel's this comes in the
aftermath of the Pompeii level explosion
from last week that blanketed The
Landing Ash I was expecting this to
Kickstart a massive battle in which the
Orcs And a doll were now free and the
survivors had to fight them off whilst
trying to escape what we get though is a
slower paced entry with several scenes
in which characters just sit about and
talk to each other this happens in the
case of Galadriel and Theo alaron and
jiren during enduring Diesel and jiren
and Nori and her mother I'm trying not
to rag on the show too much as I know
people genuinely just want to hear the
breakdown I feel it's taking one step
forward and two back with its pacing and
Dynamics now Galadriel is stormed by a
horse on fire early on and this brings a
lot of symbolism with it typically
horses on fire uses symbols to represent
Machinery or fiery engines Tolkien was
against industrialization and this is
why characters like Saruman and the Orcs
were depicted as forces that pushed it I
think this horse is meant to represent
that the beautiful Southlands have now
been changed in these giant
industrialized Landscapes that have
destroyed the picturesque place that it
once was now there's actually way more
survivors in this scene than I thought
would have come from a volcanic eruption
of this size and the characters all get
covered in Ash Pompeii still stands as a
monument to how devastating events like
this can be but our core cast of
characters all end up Surviving I think
the imagery of this is purposely shot to
look like the aftermath of the Twin
Tower attacks with people blanketed in
Gray Ash whilst they wander through the
smoke now I know that the show has to
have these characters survive but it was
a bit weird seeing houses completely
burned in the the ground whilst
Galadriel was fine even after taking the
full force of it I kind of wish that
they taken cover last week instead of
framing it like this because there's a
bit of a disconnect seeing people find
whilst the landscape looks worse than
Sunderland economy suck as now
Millennial is pulled out the fire by a
seal door and the character would later
go on to name one of his sons the same
thing with this show creating a reason
for why that's the case isildo ends up
getting lost and there's a scream of his
name which to me sounded similar to how
elrond shouted it during The Fellowship
of the Rings this would of course end up
happening in mordo and from here we cut
to a stream a sealed or died in the
fellowship after jumping into a river
and this could be them matching up the
shots to foreshadow that event here We
join the half words and discover that
they've ended up settling on the edge of
Mordor the land is signs of Ash in The
Brute there's also a giant volcanic rock
that's ended up crashing there though I
was thinking a stranger might end up
creating the Shire when they started
saying about how long they could last
there I don't think that's the case
looking at the map of Middle Earth this
is the complete opposite end tomorrow so
either the volcano shot things up for or
they are on the edge of mortal it did
travel through the marshes that I
thought could be the dead marshes and
they also end up talking about Greenwood
the gray which would go on to become
mirkwood therefore I think this is a
proto-shire that shows the half butts
can settle somewhere instead of
constantly being on the move there was a
tweet earlier in the week about how
Hobbit doors may be around like Wheels
because the half butts were always on
the move so maybe they'll tie things in
with that after accidentally becoming a
Peril The Stranger ends up leaving and
he's stalked by feminine who is called
the dweller along with her is the
aesthetic and also the Nomad a former
means someone who practices discipline
with a ladder meaning someone who
travels from home to home without a
permanent place to live the plate They
Carried had the strangest constellation
on the back of it and they clearly
possess magical abilities I think
they're likely going to be the strangers
first major fight so we can see how
truly powerful he is I can imagine
that's the way storyline wraps up next
week with him discovering the
constellation on the plate and thus
potentially getting a confirmed about
who he is it did cross my mind that it
might be a misdirect and that they could
actually be forces of good that want to
find him and teach him things but they
set the half at home a light so also
nicer line with logo saying you harm her
hair on their foot and later he's asked
to give them a moment to weep similar to
what happens with the fellowship after
the death of Gandalf Nori ends up giving
him an apple and this is typically seen
as a symbol of knowledge and wisdom
apples popped up last week with a seal
door throwing one away or as a stranger
ends up taking it with him the dweller
and Co end up going after him but they
fall for the old I think you went that
way mate cutel Ron promising to pimp the
dwarf's caves if they help them get the
mithril which king jiren instantly shuts
down even with elrond's plays about
liking the video being half elf and his
son's words he still sees things dying
off as being a natural part of the world
King jiren brings up our lay who in the
law create the dwarves they will secrete
the Trees of valinor and convince aru to
bring Life To The Ends he doesn't want
to dig deep to help the elves but he
ends up unleashing the balrog Anyway by
dropping the leaf into the darkness the
mithril pushes the corruption back on
said leaf and therefore I think it's
gonna be used as a way to fight in the
future battles against the forces of
Sauron mithril was said to be made from
light contained in the two trees of
valinor and we of course saw a balrog
fighting over this in episode 5. now one
thing I love about the show is the
dwarves and to me are one of the
strongest elements of the series it will
give really heartfelt and memorable
performances and though I'm ragging on
the show a bit in general I think this
slower Pace moments with them generally
tend to work as what they're saying has
meaning and conviction diesel especially
seems to be the heart of their Dynamic
and after some mother-in-law jokes she
gives during the nurse to help his
friend after seeing what mitral does
rather than saying goodbye elron says
the Marie which means go towards
goodness as well as be well I'll
swelling Neil desperately searches for
his son who doesn't end up turning up in
the end I might even do something where
he's captured by the enemy but Sauron
could let him go after realizing he has
a path ahead that could help him out I
also think it's possible that Galadriel
and Hal bran might save him as they
travel off together towards the end of
the episode look I don't know mate I'm
just throwing theories out there and
Muriel also ends up becoming blind which
will no doubt allow farazone to seize
power easily I think they're going to do
something similar to President Roosevelt
who in case you don't know was paralyzed
due to polio however Vegeta people
helping him stand and boots that he
could lean on it took a long time before
the public realized he kept it a secret
because he didn't want to seem weak and
they seem to be doing something similar
with the queen regent because she's
blind farazone can tell her whatever he
wants and he could end up using this as
a way to take over the Owen Galadriel
wander the Wilderness too and after she
gives him her sword the pediscus
killerborn in case you don't know this
is galadriel's husband and also the Lord
of lothlorian God Galadriel does say
that kellerborn was slain but we know
from the timeline that this isn't the
case I think he's taking out the picture
so it can probably do some sexual
tension between collateral and Hal brand
without making it look like she's a
dirty cheat will you be on Cheaters soon
though I promise you that either way
this scene is very reminiscent and went
brother only the hobbits hid under the
tree whilst the ring wraith stalked them
Orcs move overhead and the shots are
very similar with swords being drawn in
the general positioning of the
characters elsewhere during an hour on
the court digging too deep and the way
the mithril threats slowly light up is
similar how it happened when Gandalf lit
it up in the fellowship alron is Jazzy
jeffed out kazadum and King Duren talks
to his son about how he was a sickly
child but that he saw greatness in him
he talks about seeing the Gray beard of
an old Dwarven King and Dwarven kings
were thought to be reincarnated from
their ancestors during the third would
eventually going to become June the
fourth the show has changed that up for
its own mythology to have the two
interacting with each other they both
had their own views with his son saying
his father is holding him back whilst
also wanting him to be a great dwarf
very much a covenant Father and Son
relationships that sees June the fourth
being stripped of his necklace El India
wrestles with a seal those host Barrick
and he and his son of course had a scene
involving it last week America's sat on
his way and this reminded me a lot of
how Bill the pony was sent back home
when the fellowship arrived at Moria he
knows the way Sam don't worry about him
he knows the way home through those 40
miles of mountains and then 500 miles of
field it'd be home in no time Sam don't
you worry mate anyway we discovered
bronwinning around here are alive along
with Hal brand who's been badly injured
initially the new minorians want to pack
up and return home but Galadriel appeals
to Muriel and convinces her not to
abandon them into their fate she rides
up in the end back to newmanor to get
more forces I think the kingdom is gonna
be stolen from her upon her return I
think they could have cut the scene at
this point but instead we get a focus on
a lindial crying and what's one of the
most most jarring moments in the show I
don't think my guy is a bad actor and he
has delivered a lot of really good
moments but something just felt off
about this scene to me obviously he's
devastated some might be dead but the
moment just kind of loses it a bit due
to feeling almost like an insert shot
might have been the direction or
something but I think it would have been
better just to shoot him from the side
with a teardrop rolling down his cheek
instead we get another moment that's
gonna be all over the internet and it's
a shame as this could have been quite an
empowering scene I know some of you
won't mind it though so let me know if
I'm blowing it about proportion but yeah
I personally just thought it was a bit
weird now the harfords make their own
fellowship with them all deciding to
join up there's a moment in Fellowship
when Mary and Pippen joined the group
and it's all about not going at it alone
Galadriel and Nishi wants to go to
gilglad but she and Hal bran end up
riding off in the end after king during
orders for the mithril hole to be sealed
up he throws a leap in that shows you
can't put the toothpaste back in the
tube we end with a Dar announcing the
Southlands on her more and close out
with a weird a weird stylistic choice I
personally just don't think the changing
of the text like this fitting with this
style and aesthetic of the show and it
felt like something we would get in a
90s TV series I think it would have been
done way better if we just cut to Black
and heard a dull whisper Mordor or
something but either way that ends the
episode and it's an episode that again
I'm pretty torn on it has its high
moments but for 70 minutes there's not
really a lot that goes on that feels
important much like episode 5 I think
you could have probably skipped a lot of
these scenes and still ended up at the
same point first in the finale the show
has a habit of doing very little until
the last couple of minutes where teases
something big for next time however
we've been through that enough now to
the point where it often fails to
deliver on it the week after and because
of this it's becoming a bit difficult to
get excited now Amazon have promoted the
finale as being something big and I
really hope it is I know there's some of
you out there who think that I play up
my negative opinions with using clicks
but on the whole when a show is well
liked my videos do much better it's
always better for my channel when I'm
really enjoying something and the
viewers are too but I have to be honest
with myself and say I'm not really
having a good time with this I've even
had people saying they help Amazon
remove my Early Access but that shows me
they just want to live in a world where
everyone agrees with them and that
people should only be allowed to give
their opinions if it's extremely
positive I personally I'm just being
honest and I'm really struggling to see
where the budget is gone with each
episode costing more to make than
Deadpool did which I just can't get my
brain around this is the most expensive
TV show of all time and it should really
be a spectacle but it feels like not
that much really happens and it's just
characters discussing how they feel
rather than showing it with their
actions I do hate saying stuff like this
as I know a lot of work will have went
into the show but yeah this is probably
my least favorite episode of the entire
series I think the Miss wires with the
crying scene and the text as well just
felt like a bad way to put across their
point and just attracted from me rather
than ramping things up but what could be
a big finale the show is so poorly paced
and looking back I'm thinking there's a
lot of weird choices and what they spend
their time on thinking about it I think
episode 1 would have been way more
powerful if the entire entry was the
opening montage and then we ended with a
big gut punch which came with the death
of galadriel's brother instead of
focusing on things like that though and
giving them the proper time a gloss over
it for episodes like this where we spend
ages talking about minor things feels
weirdly imbalanced and I think moments
like that could have been given more way
to them rather than what we get here if
you disagree obviously let me know below
I I do hate hating on a show you know
like I said it's much more beneficial
for me if people are really enjoying it
but I have to be honest and and just
give my true feelings so that's my
thoughts on the series this week I'm
still a bloody shulo uh so yeah keep
sending me free stuff and we are in
competition right now and giving away
Thor 11 thunder on the 15th of October
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now save that to you then message
me on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you
want something else to watch make sure
you check out one of our house of the
dragon videos which will be linked on
screen right now we go over lots of
stuff that you need to know for the
series so definitely head over there
right after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
Paul you've been the best and I'll see
you next time take care peace